hi everyone okay welcome to Hangover
[ __ ] number two I hope you're not
feeling too however this morning my name
is Oliver ash you can find me on twitter
at this user name and today i'm going to
be talking about how i built an offline
page for the Guardian com I work at the
Guardian previously I worked on the
content management system which is a web
application you can see here this is
called composer if you want to hear more
about that you can come talk to me later
but essentially this is the tool that
all the journalists key is to publish
content to the web and also print and
now I work on the website and so if you
hump me into the Guardian com this is
what it looks like I'm going to begin by
comparing web and native and how these
two different platforms compare when it
comes to performance in a native app
when you open when you open it it will
download some content and cash it so the
next time you're open it and you're
offline well you just see the stale
content this is a guardian up I'm
offline but I can still see the homepage
I can actually navigate into content and
I can still read it the same thing if
the server is down I'll see the stale
content if I have a poor connection then
I'll see the stell content whilst we try
to get the new content that might take a
long time but at least I'm seeing
something in the meantime and if I have
a good connection then I'll briefly see
the cell content and then I'll see the
new content once it arrives we will know
this because we will use native apps
every day but on the web well if you're
flying you don't really get anything if
I try to go to the Guardian calm and I'm
a flying I just get this chrome or Fline
page little and in fact there is a game
you can play if you tap on the dinosaur
it's quite fun I'm not very good at they
if the server's down again I'll just get
this page it's not very useful and if I
have a poor connection then you're going
to be if you try to let the Guardian
drama anyone
so you're going to be staring at a white
screen until the content of isles and if
you have a good connection then finally
we have the happy path you see the new
content and and and the offline page is
actually becoming something of a symbol
like this is an advertisement in the cap
underground station or in the capital of
Argentina and you can see that the the
dinosaur that I just showed you on the
offline page and is actually used in an
advertisement say what why don't we use
that as an opportunity to push our brand
and so to give the user something useful
so we can we can do that we can do
better and as a start the guards
intercom we built an offline page so if
i'm on https page on the guardian and i
go offline when i refresh that page I'll
see the offline page and it has a
crossword you can play but I'm not very
good at crossword this way have a go
there if you want to try it out we are
we have limited it to the smashing fire
/ developer blog section and that's
because of browser bucks which I will
explain later so I'm gonna I'm going to
break down how we built it in four steps
the first step is introducing service
workers I before I go into that I just
want to emphasize that this is something
that I was able to build in less than a
day I think mid 2015 Jake came into the
Guardian office to talk about service
workers and I thought okay I'm going to
use this as an opportunity to try and
learn and spilled something and I was
able to build what you just saw in less
than a day I did have to do some
polishing to get into production but
that was no more than a few hours so
everything you see here you can learn
you can I want to inspire you to go
ahead and pay with these technologies
yourself so what is the service worker
well
I don't know if this needs an
introduction really but i'm going to i'm
going to do an introduction but create
chrome dev summit last year i think
someone counted how many times the word
service workers was used and they
counted 66.5 I actually think that's
probably a guess and I think it was
probably mentioned more than a hundred
times but there we go and of course if
you if you didn't know what service
workers well then you probably
discovered yesterday that actually it's
just a cake and you can eat service
workers so a service worker is a script
that runs in the background and it's
useful for features that require no user
interaction so that might be listening
to a push event and you might want to
show a notification when you receive a
push oven we might be intersecting and
handling Network requests which is
something that will be using
specifically for the affluent page as
well as I'll show you and in the future
it will be used for other things like a
background think if you have some data
that you want to update periodically or
alarmed if you want to show a reminder a
specific time to a user and also maybe
geofencing so when you enter a
geographical perimeter you want to
perform some action all of these things
the service work is a perfect place to
have to have those features and it's
also a progressive enhancement because
if you don't have service worker then
your your website just works as it as it
was before to do two things tonight it's
https only and it's supported in chrome
or opera and firefox a moment but maybe
safari next decades we'll see
and for the observant among you you may
realize that actually the Guardian isn't
on HTTPS but we are migrating we're
actually migrating pay section by
section these are the ones that you can
go to today and they are HTTPS and if
you go to any of these page you'll get
our service worker and if you want to
learn more about how the migration is
going come and talk to me afterwards but
I think we've essentially ruled out as
advertising as a problem so we've almost
got the green light to go for the HTTPS
so creating and registering a service
worker just imagine me we create a empty
file called service worker George S and
on an HTML page we're going to have a
script that tells the browser we want to
register it we have a service worker
registered now but nothing is really
happening the request is just going
straight from the page to the server and
back if if you want to see yourselves
worker you can actually use the dev
tools to see that if you go into the
resources panel and I can service work
it down the left-hand side likewise in
chrome if you go to about debugging hash
workers and you can see your service
worker there as well so we have we have
a we have a service worker but it's not
doing anything what we need to do is we
need to we need to download some
resources ahead of time and the show to
the user when they're offline we want to
prime the cash and service worker has
something called the install event which
is the perfect opportunity to do this
and so I don't have too much code today
but this is just to show you how you
prank ash we in the install event we
just run a function called update cash
and that opens a new cache and it adds
three different assets to the cash the
offline page which is the HTML some CSS
which we need for that for the
homepage to work and some JavaScript and
we also we're going to version the cash
because as we see later we want to we
want to know when the user has an old
version and then we want to update it
and but you'll see that later and in our
case as you saw the offline page has a
critter has a crossword that's actually
built as a reactor reactor application
and that's all contained within within
the JavaScript that we're cashing here
so now we have a service worker and cash
but we're not doing anything still you
know the offline page doesn't work yet
request is just going straight to the
server and back so the next thing we
need to do is we need to handle requests
with something called to fetch event the
fetch event lets you intercept requests
and handle them programmatically and so
the default is just for the browser to
to make the request to the network and
in the code here which I've just added
to the bottom of the code that you saw
previously and I'm just going dude doing
what the browser were doing it anyway so
I'm not doing anything different here
but what you could do is you could fetch
for what you could fetch from the catch
cash instead or you could construct a
response programmatically so now our
service worker is actually doing
something the the requests are actually
going through the service worker to the
server and back but we still don't help
your flowing page working and let's move
on just to give you an idea of the
flexibility you have in a service worker
it is very very programmatic so you can
actually construct your own response as
you can see here I have a string of HTML
and I could just construct your response
from that string and respond with that
and that the browser is a perfectly
valid response so you have a lot of
control
so in order to use the fetch event to
serve the offline page and I need to I
need to break this down into two parts
because we have we have two different
types of content we have HTML which is
mutable and so you know the Guardian com
is some HTML and it changes every time
someone adds new contents for the
offline page will also change and every
time we make a change to it or you know
the crossword updates whereas we have we
have immutable assets like a CSS and
JavaScript once we deploy those they are
on the Internet forever and and if you
request that URL and it will it will
always return the same content so we
have different kasia strategies for
these different different types of
requests so I'm we need to handle them
separately for HTML and when when you're
offline and you make a request for some
HTML that's the time when we want to
show you offline page so what would be
is what we want to do is we want to go
to the network first because if you are
online we don't want to show the offline
page but if there is an error when we
try to go to the to the network then
we'll fall back to the cash and this is
a path pattern known as network first
then cash this is the same in fetch
event you saw earlier I the only change
I've made here is I've guarded the
response and I'm only handling HTML
requests and the way I do that is by
looking at the request headers and so
the request accept header and tells me
whether or not the browser accepts HTML
and all only I'll only handle the
request if the browser does except HTML
that's not useful in itself but we will
elaborate so moving on we hit we have
that we're doing the fetch to the
network and we want to fall back to the
cash fetch returns a promise so if
you're offline fetch will return
will return a rejected promise so we
catch that promise rejection and we
retrieve something from the cache which
is that offline page and now if you're
offline you get this beautiful offline
page that something's missing I hope you
can notice we're missing some styling
and some behavior so we now need to
handle asset requests and as I said
earlier these were immutable so what we
want to do really is we want to go to
the cash straight away because we know
that they're going to be in there and
this is how we do that if it's not HTML
then we'll just look in the cash to see
if there's a an entry that matches the
request that's coming through ah that's
not going to work for things which
aren't in the cash so we need to we need
to take a different approach we want to
go to the cash first and if it's not in
a cash then we'll try the network and
this is good for any CSS or JavaScript
any assets that we don't have in the
cash because remember remember we're
only cashing things which are needed for
your flame page and the way we do that
is the same code we had before and
cashes match returns at promise and
we'll see if the value of that from its
is undefined or not and if there is a
value then we'll just use that otherwise
we'll go to the network using the fetch
function the final part to talk about is
updating the crossword so we publish new
crosswords every day we have an avid
user base and it would be great if the
offline page contained the latest
crossword and how would you do this well
the way we're currently doing it is in
the global scope of our service worker
with we're seeing if the cache is
updated or not and we know we know that
by looking at the cache name that we
defined earlier as I said earlier we've
version the cash so if there isn't a
version that matches today's date then
we know it's not up to date and if it's
not up to date then we'll run the same
function that we ran in the install
event the update cash function and then
once that finishes we can safely delete
the old caches in the future we might
want to use the background sync API for
this instead it's kind of it's a bit of
a hack doing it doing it here and
actually the reason this works is
because the browser closes the service
worker and disabled memory and then it
will boot it up again when you visit
that page again and so this code in the
global scope actually gets it gets a
chance to run quite frequently sorry
there we go we have an offline page and
everything works next I want to talk
about what we might use service worker
for in the future on the Guardian calm
and you're flying page right now is a
little bit insignificant because of our
HTTPS migration is still ongoing and
also browser support but it will
increase in significance you can imagine
a year from now when browser support is
really good and we're on HTTPS loads of
people will see that offline page so we
would like to extend it maybe do what
native apps to show the stale content or
download content ahead of time and show
them show the user personalized content
for them because we know what you've
been reading recently and we also have a
feature called save for later we could
use that as a action that states I want
to read this offline and we could also
go full you're flying fast and I'll fly
first what does that mean it means when
I request the HTML I get a response
instantly with just a shell of the page
and that's coming from the cash
via the service worker that improves
experience quite significantly for users
with poor connections as we saw earlier
when we compared native and web if you
if you have a poor connection you open a
website you're just going to be staring
a white screen so service workers allows
you to to avoid that situation and give
a much better experience and yeah we
could show you Stella content whilst
clutching new new new content as well so
just to create a very happy demo me to
demonstrate what I meant by that this is
kind of how many content websites why
today you tap on a link and then nothing
happens for 5-10 seconds depending on
your network connection and then finally
the new content downloads and it flashes
and it appears on screen but you're not
really giving you any feedback would it
would be much better if when I tap on
that link i get feedback straightaway to
say okay something is happening
something floating and then when the new
content arrives it just appears and that
is what we mean by show architecture i
also want to mention some problems and
caveats that I had when I was working on
this mentioned earlier that there were
browser bugs as a weird bargain chrome
where any redirect from HTTP to HTTPS
would result in there in a view of the
offline page even if you went offline
and we also had a weird bug in Firefox
where cookies were dropped and which
meant that or no those odd behavior like
users on HTTPS sections couldn't use
come commenting for some reason but we
worked around those and they weren't
they weren't too severe and it's it's
been good to push and identify those
lace bugs I think the vol being fixed
now and another problem we had was in
interleaving of versions in the seed in
cash and I want to explain what I mean
by that because I think
other people might have this problem
when they when they tried to cash wings
in a service worker so we have a service
worker and that caches I've simplified
the example here that this cash is two
things it caches the offline page which
it's an HTML and it caches some CSS and
that offline page when you try to run it
it will try to load that CSS and if if
we looked at how things were cashed in
our CDN when you request the service
worker for the first time okay the CDN
is going to cash that we say it's going
to cash it for 60 seconds when you
request your flowing page for the first
time the CDM will cash that as well for
60 seconds in the same with the CSS but
because the CSS is an immutable thing we
can cash that for much longer but at
some point in time we do a deploy and
someone changes a service worker and
when you when someone makes a request
for that the CDM wall will cash the new
version if the old version has fallen
out of the cash and that leads to a
situation like this where you have the
new version of the service worker which
is telling the browser to cash the old
the old version of the offline page
because the CDN still has that version
and and the new version of the CSS and
of course when you try to run the
offline page because you'll get an old
version the CSS just won't work because
it will be trying to lay the version 1
into the version 2 is a difficult
situation and we could have fixed it one
way we could have fixed it is by naming
versioning the service worker and the
offline page but the way we actually
fixed it was using something I guess you
would call a cache manifest and so this
is just some Jason that has some HTML
for the offline page and a list of
assets to download
and because a cache manifest will will
be a single entry in the CD in cash you
can guarantee that there will be no
interleaving of versions so there we go
finally why why did I why did I do this
I mean it's fun to experiment with new
browser technology of course but
although there's insignificant usage due
to HTTPS and browser support right now I
think it's good to plant the seeds and a
lot of people don't realize that the
webcam work offline and so I think it's
good to start demonstrating that and
people will start to see the product as
as these things do increase in support
and also it's good to iron out browser
bugs that pushes the web for words and I
really like this quote by Nolan awesome
if we only use features that work in ie8
we're condemning ourselves to 98 world
so I think I really really would like to
encourage everyone to like trying new
service workers today because you can
start building really great things of
them so in conclusion and service
workers allows us to progressively
enhance the experience for users who are
offline and but also uses with poor
connections and its really really easy
to build an offline page and and it's a
really good place to start so go ahead
and have a go here is some third reading
I wrote a blog post about all of this if
you want to read that and there's also a
great explainer on service workers on
Alex Russell's github and you can
actually visit the Guardian service
worker if you want to take a look at
what code we have in there I will admit
it's not exactly the same as what you've
seen here because I've had to work
around browser bugs and things like that
and but that's life thank you very much
thank